Reggie Miller is how old is Reggie is he
like 52 but when when you see reg looks
like he's in his 40s Reggie will be on
the call with Kevin Harlan for thundered
spurs this Thursday night that's at 9:30
Eastern on TNT reg good morning how are
you I'm doing great now the older I got
as a basketball player when I entered
3738 and I retired in 39 I was blessed
to have a young nucleus around me that
propelled me the Ron Artest Jermaine
O'Neal al Harrington Jonathan bender
Jamaal Tinsley so Donnie Wallace did a
good job of surrounding me with that
youth that was the next generation so
that's why we continue to win was
because not only did we have young
players that were hungry and talented
but I was fortunate enough to still play
with like Austin Crozier Jeff foster my
last year Dale Davis came back so we
still had the influx of veteran players
mixed with this youth I think that's why
Tom Brady feels energetic every time he
enters the stadium is because he always
be playing with young players but he is
still surrounded by the guys that helped
win championships with him so I agree
yeah we all get old with age but if you
can inject some youth in there at those
key positions that keeps your superstar
engaged
speaking of youth if you redrafted who
would be the number one overall pick
this year Luka no question look the game
has changed and I keep saying this as
well as Aiden will be eventually he'll
be a good player he won't be a great
player Luka will be a great player in
today's age you've got to have guys that
range from 65 to about six eight six
nine that can do everything that can
guard multiple positions that can shoot
from range that could handle the
basketball big men are dinosaurs and
this game is cyclical I'm sure and I'm
sure at some point the big bin will be
relevant again but into
Days games you've got to have guys that
do a little bit of everything and Aiden
runs the floor and he can't face you up
and knock down a jump shot but you're
not playing guy big good guys are
playing with her back to the basket like
Shaq like David Robinson like Patrick
Ewing like Hakeem Olajuwon Kareem those
days are gone so it's all about face up
off the dribble threes
going coast-to-coast Luka would be the
number one pick easy but why wasn't he
taken number one overall didn't you have
his former coach with the Phoenix Suns
he did you know and look everyone thinks
European players when they get to the
NBA or soft or they can't play this game
this young man which people should have
understood was the Euroleague MVP at
like 16 or 17 you tell me what 16 or 17
American player could have gone overseas
and played professional and been in MVP
not not many not one I couldn't that
would come to mind so I think a few
people dropped the ball but if you were
a redrafting no question I would go with
Luca if you if you were a general
manager for an NBA team and you were
looking at Zion Williamson or you know
you want to throw and bear it in there
whoever it is like what are you looking
for right now that you know will
translate into success in the NBA
because that's the hard part when you're
looking at young players can they do
what they're doing now against big boys
can they guard multiple positions I'm
gonna be looking at the defensive end
really well I know what he can do
offensively because he has crazy
athletic ability we've all seen the
YouTube hell up so we just seen that
last highlight versus who was at Clemson
when he did the 360 dunk I know the
physical gifts that God has blessed him
with Dan can he play the game of
basketball especially at the defensive
end and he is in one's going to be a
tweener because what do they list them
as at what six seven six eight which
means he's really what six-four six-five
I hope not
but can he guard multiple positions
and canny have a consistent three-point
shot those remains two questions on Zion
Williams I know what he's gonna do in
the open court I know what he's gonna do
on the break
can you rebound his position can he
gloried his position can he make down
can he knock down in an open three these
are questions I'm sure every team that
puts him through workouts they're
probably going to camp him out on that
three-point line and see if he can be
consistent yeah and it feels like
Barrett of Duke has a better pro game or
is more Pro ready but I have to factor
in the whole social media aspect - I
mean I'm selling tickling and you said I
could have Zion or Baron I'm taking Zion
hands down because I want people to tune
in to watch my team it's like Dallas
with Luca you're you're tuning in to
watch him Aten could be better may have
better number you're not tuning in to
watch DeAndre Aiden but you will Luca
because there's a uniqueness to this
Zion there's a uniqueness to this and I
think that's part of when you're trying
to sell your team to your fanbase that
you have to factor in and I think that
with Zion I would take him number one
overall on any given night you could be
a leading story on the mothership
Network or as you mentioned you know
YouTube and a highlight anytime Zion
step steps on the floor because of his
athletic ability but my whole thing is
he's got to be well-rounded and you know
for 30 games we shouldn't be able to
find that out to see if he's
well-rounded now that League play has
started you'll get a better gauge of his
basketball sense because when you're
playing non-conference games you really
don't get a sense of that when you have
to face teams in your conference twice
that's when you kind of get a chance to
see in conference tournaments you get a
chance to see who really has game and I
will also throw in cam reddish I think
cam reddish his game may translate at
the pro level better than it does at
Duke because of his ability to stretch
the floor and shoot the basketball
shooting if you can shoot I tell young
player
now if you can choose that's one thing
that can keep you in the league 10 to 15
years especially in today's games having
a reliable jump shot and obviously being
in the right mix where they utilize that
but if you can shoot the basketball
consistently you will have a job in the
Association Chris Webber was on the show
last week he said Duke would get smoked
by the worst NBA team absolutely would
be a joke I hate when people compare
that has there been has there been a
team though reg a college team in recent
memory could the Fab 5 have played
against the worst NBA - no ok not that
era or even in today's era today would
have forgotten smoke it they were got
any gentlemen ok but no the only team
and I'm gonna go back that could have
competed versus an NBA team was baby
back in those UCLA you know when the
wall cinder was a freshman and he
couldn't play on the varsity team villus
team maybe maybe maybe but it's it's
such a night in day scenario between
college and pros I mean I you could
almost put a collection of college
all-stars versus the worst NBA team it
wouldn't be a beatdown it would be a
better game but the pro team would still
win I want to bring up the comments that
Daryl Morey had to say the Houston
general manager who said the James
Harden could be the best offensive
player of all time and could average 40
points a game your thoughts he's the
best offensive player in today's games
no question with the rules cater to
freedom of movement where you can't
touch and he has mastered how to draw
contact in and make you reach in foul
and get to the free-throw line 11 times
the game as a guard he is the best
offensive player in today's game could
he averaged 40 now well we've seen that
over the last 130 14 games
it's 40 so yeah I mean they want freedom
of movement which is great they want
scoring as you just mention for fans and
fanbase that brings eyes to the
television and into yours arenas the
league encourages that so I do not argue
order amore I agree that he is the best
offensive player that this game has seen
since over the last probably since Kobe
yeah probably since Kobe because Kobe
the thing that separates to me Kobe and
James Harden
Kobe had impeccable footwork he
fundamentally found Kobe was as close to
MJ that I probably have ever seen
there's a lot of looseness to James
Harden's game he's got good footwork
though reg I just said good footwork I
didn't say anything about traveling or
not I mean just good footwork there do
you think that James Harden could could
James Harden get 81 points in again you
know I cuz he's got at least 50 11 times
in his career 81 no but I would not be
surprised if he hits the 70 mark 81
Allen think will ever be done again but
him and Steph Curry I think both can
knock on the door of 70 because of their
abilities to get hot from beyond the arc
I mean both can give you 10 3 10 to 15
game threes in a game harden you get 15
free throws I will not be surprised if
not this season our next James Harden
gets at least has a 17-point game but I
don't see Steph Curry doing it because
he has so many other weapons unless
those guys just go we're gonna feed you
plus they're gonna blow out somebody
where's Houston yeah I mean that's the
close game yeah the Lakers Obie's favor
yeah
yeah when they face Toronto I mean it
was a close game that he had to stay in
there and play with Golden State it
feels I could get away from you know
another team and Steph wouldn't stay in
there where is Houston
you know Harden may have to stay on the
floor did you make a big deal over you
know LeBron and that documentary or the
TV show where he talked about after
beating Golden State then he felt like
he was the greatest player of all time I
know that made some headlines what did
you make of that uh well first of all I
think we want our superstars kind of
having that bravado
I mean look he said what he's you know
that's that's how he feels if he feels
that he is the greatest of all time it's
all subjective everyone everyone's gonna
have their opinion on who they believe
is the greatest player who you know who
they went against I'm sure there's guys
in this era that absolutely believed
that LeBron James is the greatest of all
time because they never had to face
Jordan they never had to face cream--
abdul-jabbar Magic Johnson Larry Bird
Oscar Robertson Jerry West so it's it's
all subjective it's different eras it's
different rules you we just never hear
magic or Michael saying that and I think
it took people by surprise when we
actually saw LeBron James saying yeah I
am that made me the greatest of all time
if that's how he perceives himself
that's great I mean we want our
superstars you know thinking they're the
best I felt that I was the best I knew I
wasn't I would never say that but you
want you kind of want to you know give
your team and yourself hope personally I
don't believe he's the greatest of all
time but I have no problem with him
thinking that he bird did and magic had
to think they were the best players of
all time but it wouldn't we didn't have
social media so it wouldn't have rubbed
people the wrong way like who does magic
think he is saying he's better than
Oscar Robertson or curry you know
whoever but with LeBron in social media
it's you know it's a great hot take to
have where you're gonna either wit be
with him or against him and you know I
think that's why this got headlines your
and the thing about it the thing about
it is most people witnessed mj6 finals
six and oh six Finals MVP
and he's still obviously you know owner
of the Hornets and he's still relevant
in there so when he says I'm the
greatest when LeBron says I'm the
greatest of all time people I will hold
hold on a second
don't forget about that black hat in
Chicago and people need to remember
Magic Johnson Hakeem Olajuwon
it's all subjective it's who you follow
who was your favorite what memories you
have what brings you back
LeBron has some very memorable great
moments as an unbelievable player but he
also has some hiccups along the way as
well in the final
you can't say that about MJ he's even
the great magic Johnson magic went to
the final foot nine times and he only
won five times so is he in that class
what about the Big O what about Bill
Russell you know I mean the most
decorator of all our players in the
Association so again subjective if he
feels that I have no problem with that
it's just that there's historians that
are out there that have seen everyone it
would probably be like kind of slow your
roll a little bit LeBron I get it is the
under Mount Rushmore you and I have had
this conversation I had to take off my
guy to put them there and it still pains
me okay every day I wake up but I feel
odd the curse of Larry Bird is gonna get
me reg if LeBron wins the title in Los
Angeles can you then say
LeBron's the greatest better modern era
in the next three or four years we got a
four year window here if he wins a title
with the Lakers would you then anoint
him
best player of all time no but that is
balling to win three championships with
three different organizations which I
believe has never been done correct
I believe that uh Paulie yes so the
winning one in Miami Cleveland and if he
eventually wins the one in LA that's
something that magic Michael Larry
Bill Russell they they have no claim to
that yes yes Pauling there are two
players to win rings with three
different teams Robert Horry would be
one and bench player Oh Steve Kerr John
Salley John Salley Oh Detroit LA and
Chicago you're right would you have hung
on just to win one title yeah we had a
squad that was a WOD reg will be on the
call with Kevin Harlan for Thunder Spurs
this Thursday night at 9:30 Eastern on
TNT reg good to talk to you I'll talk to
you soon Theodore you're always the best
love you Dan thank you brother for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]